we're gonna need tough serious people in
our politics to bring our country back
from the brink
and we may be getting one not the hero
we deserve
but the hero we need that would be mark
mccloskey you'll remember mark mccloskey
and his wife
holding those he had the the it looked
like an ar-15
she had that little james bond gun and
when blm
started storming up and breaking their
property they did not roll over they did
not lie down they did not
please take whatever you want because of
your claims of historical grievance and
no they pulled out their guns and
pointed that at them and said get off my
property
get off my lawn i shouldn't get off my
lawn now
so they also did this while wearing
their like great brooks brothers you
know pink polo shirt
white chinos or you know khaki colored
chinos
anyway i was hoping that either
the mccloskeys would become magazine
cover models for the cover of the new j
press catalog
or that they would get involved in
politics looks like it's going to be the
latter
by the way i spoke to mark mccloskey
right when all this happened because
there was a rumor that he's a democrat
or something and supported blm
he said that's just not true he does not
do that he gave like 50 bucks once to
his
democrat buddy who was running for dog
catcher or something but he's a lifelong
conservative republican
so he is considering running for u.s
senate in missouri
my hot take on this i don't really know
very much about mark mccloskey i don't
know anything really about the other
candidates for senate
but my my first gut really
analytical reaction is
awesome great super cool great love that
love i'm really glad he's running for
senate
i don't i don't know about his political
philosophy
i don't know his his
intricate ideas about entitlement reform
or something like that
i don't i don't know about his personal
history
here's what i do know that guy stood up
to blm when it counted
when when it was getting real when it
was on the line
when a a violent angry mob came to
destroy his property and threaten him
and his wife
he stood up to them and he faced legal
threats because of that
didn't care faced physical threats
obviously because of that didn't care
he stood up to defend not just his
property
not just his life but to defend what is
right
to stand up for justice that gives him i
think a real
real advantage in the race all the jokes
about how great they looked you know and
the polos and the guns and everything
that actual those images did represent
something they weren't just memes
they actually represented a stance for
justice
very few people are willing to do that
in washington
gives him gives him a very good
advantage wait a second
way down not so fast pull your hands
away from the keyboard or from
your screen you've got to smash
that button you got to subscribe you got
to like
you've got to make sure that you get
all of the videos that are coming up
because youtube doesn't necessarily love
our content
they don't always want to promote it so
make sure that you are there
for all the latest videos see you next
[Music]
time
you